We dedicate this day to all the heroes and heroes
in this country and the rest of the world
who sacrificed in many ways
and surrendered their lives so that we could be free.
Their dreams have become reality.
Freedom is their reward.
We are both humbled
and elevated by the honour and privilege that you,
the people of South Africa
have bestowed on us
as the first president of a united democratic,
non racial and non sexist South Africa
to lead our country out of the valley of darkness.
We understand it still
that there is no easy road to freedom.
We know it well
that none of us acting alone can achieve success.
We must therefore act together as a united people
for national reconciliation,
for nationwidered,
for the birth of a new world.
Let there be justice for all.
Let there be peace for all.
Let there be work,
bread, water and salt for all.
Let us know that for each the body,
the mind of the soul
have been freed to fulfill themselves. Never,
never and never again
shall it be that this beautiful land
will again experience the oppression of one by another
and suffer the indignity
of being the skunk of the world.
The sun shall never set
on so glorious a human achievement.
Let freedom pray. God bless Africa. I thank you.